So many people's exams are over
or you guys are about to finish an exam, so
now I want to give you some tips
which you can do during these holidays,
first of all you can purchase your hobbies,
you can do painting.  I like to do
drawing and other outdoor games in the bedroom,
anything you can do here,
after that you
can take a little preparation for your next class, if you
are going to 10th by heart then you can do it in 10th.  If
you want to write in board exam then you can
take some foundation classes along with it
like you can prepare for need foundation, you can
prepare for G foundation
or you can think in this direction, the
most important thing is that we do
not think.  If we find that we cannot decide
what to do, then
you can do some of these steps.
Thoughts that are happy learning
[Music]